president biden salutes the bravery of
transgender people but not the veterans
of d-day
on d-day the aclu rejects freedom of
speech and the coalition of the woke
mobilizes against senator joe manchin
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data from big tech with
vpni trust visit expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first your reminder you're
spending way too much money on your cell
phone bill like a lot too much money and
this is why thousands of you
have been switching over from your cell
phone coverage provider over to pure
talk
usa in fact another thousand of you my
extremely wise listeners
have made the switch from your
overpriced wireless carrier to peer talk
over the past couple of months
so what exactly are the rest of you
waiting for if you're with att or
verizon or t-mobile your family could
save over 800
a year just by switching to pure talk
you get the same great coverage because
they use the exact same towers as one of
the big carriers you can even keep your
phone and your number but you will save
a fortune there is a reason pure talk is
the top rated wireless company by
consumer affairs with the absolute best
customer service team based right here
in america if that sounds good it gets
even better because right now you get
unlimited
talk unlimited text and six gigs of data
for just 30 bucks a month
and i know you're asking okay what if i
use more than six gigs of data well
they're not going to charge you for it
so i mean really you have nothing to
lose
grab your mobile phone dial pound 250
say ben shapiro
when you do you'll save 50 off your very
first month and of course hundreds of
dollars down the road
dial pound two five zero say keyword ben
shapiro to get started pure talk is
simply
smarter wireless alrighty so this
weekend
marked the anniversary of d-day of
course june 6 1944 during which allied
forces stormed the beaches of normandy
to finally take back europe from the
nazi
predations that had taken over the
entire continent effectively
starting in 1939 and onwards
it's a day that pretty much every
president has paid tribute to on the day
donald trump did so
barack obama did so george w bush did so
but joe biden did not
do so in fact according to the new york
post biden omits mention of d-day on
77th anniversary of normandy invasion
president biden seemed to have forgotten
about the anniversary of d-day the
allied invasion of northwestern germany
in northwestern europe that turned the
tide against nazi germany in world war
ii
he didn't reference the 77th anniversary
of operation overlord on either his
personal twitter account
or his official president of the united
states account on sunday the date of the
invasion he didn't mention it yesterday
either the president did highlight
his remarks in tulsa oklahoma last week
that marked the 100th anniversary of
that city's 1921 race massacre so there
was mention of of course the evils of
racism in the united states his case
being that those evils persisted today
and require
a complete remaking of the american
bargain and of course
we're going to put tremendous focus on
the evils of american history but not
the great deeds done by americans
in american history including d-day he
tweeted we're getting america back on
track from the potus account and in the
competition for the 21st century
the future will be built right here in
america from his personal account
the white house did not put out a
statement referencing d-day or any
statement at all on sunday
it did note the 40th anniversary of the
known beginning of the aids epidemic the
previous day so it's pretty obvious
where the biden administration is
putting its focus
vp harris did actually tweet something
out she tweeted out on the 77th
anniversary of d-day we honor the heroes
who stormed the beaches of normandy and
liberated a continent
we'll never forget their courage and
sacrifice joe biden also did the same
but the fact that the president of the
united states did not
but we did get tribute to the beginning
of the aids crisis
as well as the 1921 tulsa massacre is
telling as to what the priorities of
this administration are
and more importantly there's something
else that's going on in american life
that is
sort of fundamental to understand and
that is the transformation
of the words that we use to describe
things as good
right those words have changed
tremendously so perfect example
the president of the united states still
has not tweeted anything out about d-day
which of course
is this week the 77th anniversary but
joe biden
did in fact tweet out about the bravery
of young trans people
so no tweets about the bravery of young
men 18 year old
sometimes younger who are storming the
beaches of normandy
and getting killed in the process in
order to fight for the freedom of the
west
nothing about that but true bravery
apparently
is declaring that you are a member of
the opposite sex so president biden
tweeted out yesterday to transgender
americans across the country especially
the young people who are so
brave i want you to know your president
has your back during pride month
and all the time so brave okay so
let's talk for a second about the
concept of bravery i mean first let's
let's just make clear that there is no
good reason why the white house decided
to ignore d-day i mean jen sackey the
white house press secretary was directly
asked why joe biden didn't bother to pay
tribute
to dj and her answer was sufficiently
nonsensical
presidents bush obama and trump all
commemorated d-day anniversaries
on d-day on the day anniversary why
didn't president find it
well i can tell you that certainly the
uh vali his value for the role that men
and
the men who served on d-day uh and the
memory of them
the families who have kept their
memories alive over the course of years
on this
day is something the president has spoke
to many many times in the past
um it's close to his heart and i
wouldn't be surprised if there's more
we would have to say on it okay so no
good reason
why exactly the administration decided
to ignore d-day but it's the definition
of bravery i want to focus in on here
because
according to joe biden the bravery of
the men of d-day was not worthy of note
this year but the bravery of young trans
people was worthy of note so this does
require us to actually ask what
definition of bravery we're using i mean
for years
i've joked publicly that our definition
of bravery has changed rather radically
since normandy
because it seems that the old definition
of bravery was a more classical
definition of bravery the new definition
of bravery is i'm living my truth and i
demand your applause
that is the new definition of bravery my
truth your applause
and and if you don't applaud then i
guess that you know that just makes me
even more brave because
one day i will force you to applaud okay
so to understand
how the notion of truth and courage has
morphed over time i think we first have
to understand the classical definition
of bravery there's no better place to go
for a classical definition of courage
than back to aristotle
and i know it sounds pedantic but these
words do demand definition because the
change in fundamental terms in our
society demands
some sort of explanation we're
redefining terms willy-nilly we're
redefining terms like man and woman and
now we're redefining
basic human attributes and virtues like
courage so aristotle spends an
inordinate amount of time in nicomachean
ethics
talking specifically about the
definition of courage what makes a
person courageous or not
first of all there's a certain irony to
the fact that the word used in greek to
describe courage
andrea is actually literally manliness
right the idea of courage is connected
with being a man
because the idea is that men are the
ones who are supposed to put themselves
at physical risk in order to protect
something higher the aristotelian
definition
of courage involves a few things first
of all aristotle's nicomachean ethics
it's it's it's a book of
about virtue it's it's sort of different
aristotle's definition of what makes a
good person
than even the biblical definition the
biblical definition suggests that
there's a bunch of rules and if you
follow these rules then this means at
the end of your life you have been a
good person
aristotle's idea of a good person later
adopted by both thomas aquinas and
maimonides
his basic idea is instead that the way
you become a good person is you
cultivate virtues within you
you cultivate character traits and the
way you cultivate those character traits
is by practicing at those character
traits in a wide variety of scenarios so
one of the virtues that he puts a lot of
focus on
is courage right manliness in the
original greek so what is that
according to aristotle virtually every
virtue is supposed to be the mean
between two wide variants and so courage
for example
is a mean between fear and confidence
right it's the it's the average
it's supposed to be right in the middle
right the goal is to find that golden
mean
and then to stick to that golden mean so
you're not supposed to be too fearful
but you're also not to be
you're not to be foolhardy you're not
supposed to just rush into the middle of
traffic or something and call yourself
courageous
on on behalf of that so what exactly
does courage constitute
courage constitutes acts performed with
knowledge of violence or risk or pain
that are on behalf of a higher goal
right they're on behalf
of what he would term a final purpose or
a t loss right
the idea would be that you're defending
something higher and you do something at
personal risk
in order to achieve that something
higher so the most
the most obvious example that aristotle
talks about is of course soldiers doing
battle
in order to defend family and friends
and homeland
right the idea there of course is that
you are putting yourself at risk to
protect
something higher right it is almost a
sort of self-abnegation
yes you're doing something noble and yes
you're doing something honorable
and aristotle even says that there are
certain types of fear as i say courage
is supposed to be somewhere between
fear and confidence there's certain
types of fear that are perfectly okay
for example aristotle specifically says
fear of shame does not make you a coward
fear of shame is actually a good thing
because it drives you
to do things that are not shameful which
is an amazing thing because in our
society
the idea is somehow that courage lies in
rejection of shame completely you're
never supposed to be ashamed of anything
you do you're not supposed to be worried
about what anybody else thinks of you
true courage is standing up to everybody
and ignoring their words about you
okay and this definition of courage was
the definition of courage
in most of the west for most of time
okay now we have sort of a new
definition of courage
and the new definition of courage is
complete self-involvement
you are courageous if you live your
truth if you're authentic
because identity itself like who you are
as a human being
in the ancient world and again
throughout most of human history
was identity lay in your relationship
with a system outside
how you adjust to the rules of your
society in fact we are brought up as
human beings to be civilized into the
rules of our society this is what
civilization means and take young
children who are perfectly authentic i
have little kids they're authentic all
the time and whatever goes through their
head comes out their mouth
that is just the way it works there's no
filter there's no brain mouth filter in
kids they're 100
authentic all of the time and they're
little monsters i love my kids kids are
not civilized the whole purpose of
civilization is to civilize them to the
rules of a society and even folks on the
left who praise authenticity they don't
really want full authenticity for
everybody
because that leads to conflict if a
religious person is authentic they might
be judgmental so we can't allow that
level of authenticity
but they lie and they say it's all about
authenticity okay well if it's all about
authenticity this cuts directly against
civilization
okay but the way we have now defined
courage is that authenticity is courage
you're living your truth you're living
your life no matter what anybody else
says
and this is because identity itself has
shifted it used to be again that you
found your identity in adjusting
yourself to your sort of place in
civilization and to the rules of
civilization
you found happiness in living by the
natural law
in the view of the ancient greeks or
living by the morality of
of the bible in judeo-christian ethics
or living by both and sort of the merger
of the two right which i talk about in
my book the rights out of history
now identity is found instead within
right true courage is finding who you
are within in the same way that a small
child would authenticity
is where everything is there's no higher
cause it's just about you and so true
bravery
in this new definition is expressing
yourself if you express it it doesn't
matter what the rules of society are it
doesn't matter whether you're doing any
good for the world
expressing yourself is the truest form
of bravery
now being authentically you is the
truest form of brain no matter the
consequences to anyone else no matter
the consequences to society
because that's a pretty wild
redefinition of what courage means
in fact it's almost a complete reversal
of what courage means you're acting
out of out of almost a pure
sense of of self-involvement without any
reference
to a higher cause or higher purpose but
i was thinking about this
yesterday and i thought you know what
maybe i'm selling the new definition of
courage short
maybe i'm selling it a little bit short
and i'll explain what i mean in just
one second about selling the new
definition of courage short i'll explain
in a second first
this summer it's gonna be a great summer
you're gonna be back out there and one
of the things that you absolutely need
when you get back out there
is a great pair of wireless earbuds you
need your raycons a pair of raycon
wireless earbuds in your ears can make
all the difference no matter what you
are listening to
you get crisp powerful beats at half the
price of other premium audio brands
raycons look great they feel even better
they come in a range of cool colors
with customizable gel tips included for
a comfortable in-ear fit
and raycons are built to go wherever you
go with quick and seamless bluetooth
pairing
and a compact charging case and let me
tell you they really do fit your ear the
way they're supposed to because you can
actually customize them to fit your ear
perfectly they come in a variety of
colors
they don't have the stems that sort of
hang out of your ears listen up raycon
is offering 15
off all their products for my listeners
here's what you've got to do to go get
it go to buyrecon.com
there you will receive 15 off your
entire raycon order it's such a good
deal you'll want to grab a pair and a
spare that is 15
off at byraycon.com once more that is b
y r-a-y-c-o-n dot com slash bend by
raycon.com get 15
off your entire raycon order today and
get ready for an awesome
summer okay so maybe my new definition
or the new definition that i think the
left is using with regard to courage
which is
which is self self proclamation
and authenticity maybe i'm selling it a
little bit short maybe there is
some sort of world changing thing
happening when you decide that you're
going to buck
all convention and you're going to
redefine basic terms like man or woman
that makes you courageous that makes you
brave even in
an older sense all that requires is a
complete rejection
of the telos of the final goal so if the
final goal was that you recognize nature
for what it is
and then you live in accordance with
nature's laws which again
is the point that aristotle is making
throughout nicomachean ethics it's a
point that was made by plato as well
and then it was a point that was adopted
by most of the judeo-christian world
and and by the way early on in the in
the islamic world as well the
everose and and off robbie if you reject
all of those final goals and you decide
there are new final goals
in which your personal self-definition
is supposed to be projected
out onto the world to change the world
then i suppose according to this point
of view that is an almost classical
definition of courage
you're putting yourself at quote-unquote
risk in order to change the entire
system
in order to change the entire society
right and in this case the personal is
political
when you declare that your sense of the
authentic you is that you are
a member of the opposite sex what you
are actually declaring is war
on the idea of sex biologically what you
are actually declaring is that the
entire society is wrong and you are
right and the entire society has to
change
you're putting yourself supposedly at
personal risk although in our society i
can't say that you're putting yourself a
personal risk
when you declare that you are that
you are not heterosexual for example it
seems more like the media is going to
celebrate you tremendously
as demonstrated by elliot page or demi
lovato but
if you are that the idea is that you're
putting yourself at personal
the personal is political your sense of
the authentic now must be projected out
into the world to change
all of the standards so what exactly is
the higher cause the higher cause is
changing all the standards
the higher cause is tearing down all the
definitions and this is how you get to
the point where the president of the
united states
is ignoring soldiers on the battlefield
77 years ago
fighting actual nazi fascists and
getting killed for their efforts
he's ignoring that in favor of the idea
that if you declare yourself a member of
the opposite sex
you in fact are acting in accordance
with some virtue called courage or some
virtue called bravery
all that takes is a reorientation a
redefinition of what your end goal is
and that is to tear down the system as a
whole and your very act
of self-definition is a is a personal
act of defiance
at those definitions which of course
have to be torn down and this of course
according to the left makes you a hero
and you can see this happening
right throughout american life now the
complete redefinition of courage
based on not merely a sort of
self-involvement but based on a deep
abiding desire to build a coalition to
tear down all of the systems of
definition
the heterosexual patriarchy the
cisgender patriarchy
all of the systems and hierarchies of
power that have been imbued in our
society
all those have to be torn down and the
minute you declare yourself not in
living in accordance with those things
you are a person who is brave you're a
person who is courageous
that is i think the deepest
philosophical point that is being made
that is buried well underneath these
sort of tweets that joe biden
is sending out and you can see this play
out in every area
of american life because here's the
thing when you look at the sort of woke
coalition that's been built
and all these members of the woke who
are patting each other on the back for
their bravery and their courage
even though they don't actually get
along inside their own halls of power
right they have serious disagreements
there are serious disagreements for
example
in the lgbt community between the ls and
the t's
right there there are serious
disagreements you have trad feminists
and traditional lesbians people like
like martina navratilova who is an
open battle with transgender rights
advocates who of course argue that there
is no definition of man and woman
that is not absolutely malleable and
lesbians argue that there is such a
thing as a woman
and we are women who who are sexually
attracted women and then you have
transgender
rights advocates who argue that a man
who identifies as a woman is now a woman
so there is no such thing
as a woman and if you are a woman who is
not attracted to a trans woman then this
means that you are in some way sexist
right there's all sorts of internal
schisms and battles that are going on
inside the woke community but if
everybody pats each other on the back
for their courage in taking on the
higher goal which is tearing down the
system as a whole
then we are ushered into a new utopian
vision
okay and that coalition it is
almost hysterically funny how
fragmentary this coalition is
and how the the how clear it is that the
goal is to cobble together a coalition
of people who disagree about nearly
everything
under a rubric of resistance so i have
to take just the most obvious
visual manifestation of this that i've
ever seen so yesterday
on pinknews.co.uk they had a story about
the progress
pride flag here's their story
the progress pride flag has been
redesigned by an intersex activist to
include intersex people
a yellow triangle with a purple circle
in it has been added to represent
intersex people community and rights
the new pride flag was designed by
valentino viciety of intersex equality
rights uk
who's an intersex activist and diva
magazine columnist continuing the
tradition of pride flags being updated
and reimagined so usually the goal of a
flag is of course to unify
right we all look at a symbol and we all
recognize our
shared humanity in that particular
symbol you look at the american flag and
it represents the states and represents
the original colonies and you say wow
that's our history
that's my flag right if you're in canada
and you see the maple leaf this has some
sort of resonant emotional meaning for
you you see the union jack you're in
britain same sort of thing
the new progress pride flag is not about
the idea that there's any sort of shared
values the idea here is that you have
your individual stripe in the flag right
it's a coalitional flag
and if you and if your coalition doesn't
appear on the flag the flag ain't for
you
so there's a cobbled together
agglomeration of people who disagree on
nearly everything
but this flag exists in opposition to
other unified ideas
i mean the flag looks frankly like a cat
vomited and then you looked at it
through a kaleidoscope i mean it's the
ugliest flag that anybody's ever seen at
least the original
pride flag is something visually pretty
to look at right it's just a rainbow
flag here you have apparently
some sort of of invasion from the left
side of the screen like it looks like a
military movement from the left side of
the screen that's black brown blue pink
white yellow
with a with a purple circle i mean it's
just visually incoherent
but that's sort of the idea is that
every single eventually we're going to
reach the point
where in opposition to the unified flags
that are provided by countries we're
going to
end up with flags in which every single
human has their own little dot we're
gonna have pixelated flags with 330
million dots one to represent you
and if your dot isn't represented in the
flag the flag doesn't represent you
anymore
right the idea is we can only be unified
in opposition to something else because
we don't share any values we can only be
unified
in opposition to another thing which is
why it is kind of important that the
department of defense
is refusing to fly the pride flag okay
so there is a big
uproar inside the biden administration
the state department decided they were
going to fly the pride flag at the state
department first of all this is insipid
okay the only flag that should fly at
the american state department is in fact
the american flag that is the only
unifying flag in american life
we shouldn't have flags with a giant
cross on it we should not have a gay
pride flag we should not have any of
those flags because again
the american flag is non-sectarian the
american flag is supposed to represent
all of us because we are all americans
nonetheless joe biden has decided
that all americans are apparently in
support of the entire lgbtq plus 2aaiz
agenda and therefore we're going to fly
this at the state department but only in
countries
where nobody's going to do anything
about it we're definitely not going to
do that like malaysia we're certainly
not going to do it in saudi arabia we're
not going to do it anywhere in the
middle east actually
well the defense department announced
yesterday that they are not going to be
flying the pride flag over military
bases first of all the fact that this
was even an issue
the fact that we were even having the
discussion about flying pride flags over
military bases
is somewhat insane right why exactly
would we fly a pride flag over a
military base
the the reason that we like why that
literally the people who are fighting
into
unless you're willing to put soldiers in
battle with the pride flag on their
sleeve right so they're living and dying
on behalf of the lgbt agenda apparently
like what is why why it is sectarian by
nature
by nature there's open debate about the
extent to which americans support
every aspect of the agenda promoted by
radical activists
some people are supportive of some some
are supportive of others some are
supportive of none
but the idea that this is representative
of some sort of unified body of opinion
in the united states is kind of crazy
okay so the department of defense
rejected this but here's what they
announced they said the reason
that they are rejecting this is not
because they're
they're reflecting any lack of respect
or admiration for people of the lgbtq
plus community
instead they're afraid that if they made
an exception then people might want to
fly other flags like they don't tread on
me flag
so it fairly incredible so they've
decided to be on all flags except the
american flag
because you might want to fly like a
don't try on me flag and that would be
super duper duper bad
again these things matter because when
we talk about what unifies us as a
country or what unifies us
as a society sure ideas of what courage
is or shared ideas of what the good is
or shared idea
of of what represents the good life for
americans these are basic ideas we
should share but we no longer share them
and so we're falling apart
as a country we'll get some more of this
depressing notion in just one second
first let us talk about the best watch
that you can buy if you don't wish to
spend thousands and thousands and
thousands of dollars
you want to talk about a great father's
day gift i'm talking about vincero
watches
vincero is loved by some of your
favorite entrepreneurs commentators and
hosts
like me i've given vincero watches to
nearly every member of my family and
they love them they're durable they look
great
they look like they are like full on
thousand dollars luxury watches
but they're going to cost you a fraction
of that ventura has over 30 000
five-star reviews from verified
customers that you can read for yourself
on their site
they think you deserve the best so their
team in san diego is always available to
help you out if you need anything
there's a reason the men's journal
recently called vincero watches
beautiful bold classic designs and the
real deal
right now is the perfect time to shop
for vincero because right now is
insurro's father's day sale
and they have what you need to buy the
perfect gift take 20 off on all their
brand new watches
and accessories get ready to see the
look on your friends and family's face
when they open up one of those beautiful
timepieces again i've given these to
like pretty much every member of my
family and extended family because they
just
are that good looking head on over to
v-i-n-c-e-r-o collective
dot com forward slash shapiro use code
dad20
your discount will be applied at
checkout but only if you access the sale
by going to
vincerocollective.com shapiro everything
on the site 20
off no exclusions including sunglasses
wallets bracelets go to my link
check out this awesome sale going on at
vincero right now
alrighty so as i've been talking about
here what you can see is a sort of woke
coalition that is mobilizing against
symbols of unity that's the reason why
we're even having a discussion about why
we should put up lgbt flags
at defense department bases it's it's a
wild idea
from the very beginning it's also the
reason why for example the democratic
party has decided that they are no
longer going to call mothers mothers
i used to every joke that i used to tell
is now a reality so i
you for years i was telling the joke
because this is what democrats
apparently think about the nature of sex
and gender
that every mother's day is actually
primary legal guardian of unspecified
gender day
and every father's day is secondary
legal guardian of unspecified gender day
well now it's not even a joke anymore
this is stuff they are literally writing
into legislation
according to the washington free beacon
president joe biden embraced the woke
terminology favored by radical left-wing
activists in his 2022 budget proposal it
refers to mothers as
birthing people birthing people yes we
used to call those women
birthing people now men can also have
babies which of course is a lie and
a one of these stupider ideas ever
posited
by anybody who has even a half
functional prefrontal cortex
birthing people birthing people like
really
in penis to people for men like what
what is this nonsense
the text of biden's record-breaking 6
trillion budget unveiled last month
includes a section highlighting more
than 200 million in healthcare spending
aimed at reducing the quote high rate of
maternal mortality
and race-based disparities and outcomes
among birthing people so first of all
even this is gendered language why
maternal mortality why not just
mortality maternal mortality that i mean
maternal means motherly
so i mean they got to get rid of that
but again the whole goal here is to tear
down definitions and true courage is
tearing down those definitions
and tearing down your rights in the
process because this is broader than
merely tearing away definitions or
redefining things
it is the militarization of it of this
approach
it's not enough to redefine things it's
not enough to tear down the hierarchies
in order for those hierarchies to be
torn down your fundamental rights must
be abridged
your rights of freedom of speech must be
abridged your right to freedom of
religion
must be a bridge for the last again the
true courage today
is in identifying how you want
internally and forcing the rest of
society
to shift its entire perspective on life
in order to account for your perspective
the rest of society has to adjust and
what that means is that their rights
must be abridged this is this is the
reason why
there's a case that's going to the
supreme court right now about whether
catholic charities ought to be able to
engage in foster decisions whether they
ought to be able to
have foster homes and whether they also
have foster agencies and the case being
made
is that because catholics actually
believe in one man one woman as the
standard for marriage and believe
that man woman child is the model for a
traditional
and healthy family that they have to be
discriminated against because if they
were allowed to actually go forward with
their foster
agencies what they would be doing is
acting in discriminatory fashion
and reins reinstituting the hierarchy
that the truly brave courageous people
are fighting to tear down
freedom of religion has to be abridged
the the basic notion of children having
a mother and a father
has to be abridged in deference to a
redefinition
and every time you fight the patriarchy
by identifying
in a way that runs contrary to biology
this means that you are a brave person
braver even than the people who stormed
the beaches of normandy who of course
were fighting on behalf of a bad cause i
mean they were fighting
truly on behalf of a re-institution of
hierarchies just
slightly better hierarchies than the
hierarchies that were being pushed by
america's fascist enemies at the time
and you're seeing america's
quote-unquote liberal institutions fall
to exactly this they have joined the
woke coalition which again
is oriented toward the destruction of
all systems of power
despite the fact that the american
systems of power which have been
gradually broadened to include more
people over time
in great and good ways despite the fact
that those systems have provided
more health more prosperity more freedom
than any systems in the history of man
by a long shot by the way those systems
have to be torn down and the aclu is now
on the side of the tearing down so the
american civil liberties union you may
notice the words civil liberties in the
middle of their title
the american civil liberties union has
now decided that civil liberties are of
no consequence whatsoever
michael powell has a piece in the new
york times titled once a bastion of free
speech
the aclu faces an identity crisis it was
supposed to be the celebration of a
grand career as the american civil
liberties union presented a prestigious
award to the long-time lawyer david
goldberger he had argued one of its most
famous cases defending the free speech
rights of nazis in the 1970s to march in
skokie illinois
home to many holocaust survivors mr
goldberger now 79 adored the aclu but at
his celebratory luncheon in 2017
he listened one speaker after another
and felt a growing unease
a law professor argued that the free
speech rights of the far right were not
worthy of defense by the aclu and that
black people experienced defensive
speech far more viscerally than white
allies
in the hallway outside an aclu official
argued it was perfectly legitimate for
his lawyers to decline
to defend hate speech mr goldberger a
jew who defended the free speech of
those whose views he found repugnant
felt felt profoundly discouraged i got
the sense it was more important for aclu
staff to identify with clients and
progressive causes than to stand on
principle he said in a recent interview
liberals are leaving the first amendment
behind now here's the thing
they are standing on principle their
principles are just not your principles
their principles are not even tolerant
of your principles their principles are
about tearing
down the systems they have to have the
aclu stripe
and that bizarre flag that we saw
earlier in which everybody has their
stripe
so as to create a coalition against the
presumed systems of power
according to the new york times the aclu
america's high temple of free speech and
civil liberties has emerged as a
muscular and richly funded progressive
powerhouse in recent years
taking on the trump administration in
more than 400 lawsuits
but the organization finds itself riven
with internal tensions over whether
it has stepped away from founding
principle unwavering devotion to the
first amendment
as national and state and state staff
members debate often hotly whether
defense of speech conflicts with
advocacy for a growing number of
progressive causes
including voting rights reparations
transgender rights and defunding the
police
so for example the new york times points
out that
chase strangio the lawyer for the for
the
transgender wing of the aclu
openly pushed for censorship of a book
by abigail schreier now the new york
times
is so unbelievably gutless that they
wouldn't even mention abigail schreier's
book here
i kid you not like they literally will
not mention abigail schreyer's book
anywhere in the article
because they too are cowards when it
comes to defense of free speech
the new york times but it is truly
incredible how the the aclu is in
excellent bellwether
for the movement of the left which at
least used to agree on certain basic
principles but no longer
now the basic principle is tear down the
system and if you're and you have to be
complicit in this it is required that
you be complicit in this
you have to shout your true bravery is
again
in supposedly risking but mostly on
behalf of a higher goal and the higher
goal is tearing down so you have a
letter
a letter from the editor of the of the
national geographic talking about the
so-called race card project
again this is national geographic a
magazine dedicated to human diversity
and differences in thought and and all
sorts and nature
it's it's literally called national
geographic
right and national geographic instead
issues a letter from the editor
about the history of race in america in
which she asks
everybody to literally carry around a
race card i'm not kidding you
quote more than a decade ago writer
michelle norris began the race card
project
in which she asked people to think about
the word race and boil their thoughts
down to six words
she expected few would respond she was
wrong so far more than five hundred
thousand people have written six word
micro essays about race hailing from
every state in about 100 countries
and territories michelle recently has
brought the race card project to the
national geographic society
as a storytelling fellow we'll support
norris in using a wealth of tools
audio video animation cartography
photography our technology to bring the
project's archived stories to life these
aren't just binary conversations about
black and white people this quilt as she
describes it
pulls at all manners of cultural threads
from latinos and indigenous people to
asians
and iranians so what's my race card
right
susan goldberg the editor-in-chief of
national geographic this is a hard
exercise but reflecting on the difficult
past year
on our fraud politics and so many frank
conversations i've had with friends and
colleagues for now
i'll leave it at this white privileged
with much to learn
okay now some of us would call this
cowardice someone should say that you
are attempting to avoid the cancellation
of the woke mob because after all
it sounds from your name as though
you're a jewish woman who is
editing a major magazine and anytime you
want you could theoretically give up
that slot to a person of color if you
are so dedicated to the proposition that
systems of power in the united states
are biased
toward white people and jews but you're
not going to do that so instead you're
going to virtue signal
but according to the left this is
internet she's expressing her authentic
fears or authentic ones and that
authenticity is directed at tearing down
the system
this is the new form of courage and this
form of courage is going to be taught in
america's public schools this is what
critical race theory effectively is
it's teaching you that true bravery lies
in taking on this this is the
anti-racism
of ibrahim x candy it is the critical
race theory of derek bell that true
bravery lies in speaking truth to power
and speaking truth to power
means tearing down all the systems and
this sort of new redefinition of courage
this sort of new redefinition
of national mission is being promoted by
none other than barack obama one of the
most divisive political figures of my
lifetime i think maybe the most
divisive political figure of my lifetime
and yes i'm including president trump in
there
because president trump followed obama
and there was a reason for that barack
obama deliberately decided he could have
been a unifying president
in 2008 he came along and said no red
sleeps no blue states
no black americans no white americans
just just americans and then
he immediately proceeded to polarize
americans along racial lines along
gender lines along lines of sexual
orientation and he proceeded to try to
cobble together a coalition
to take down the systems of power and
enshrine himself in power at the exact
same time and now of course
what is he pushing forward he's pushing
for a critical race theory which is not
a shock considering
that he was a proponent of critical race
theory back in the 1980s he was
literally
hugging derek bell right one of the
founders and promoters of critical race
theory in the 1980s when derek bell was
denied tenure at harvard law school so
here's barack obama
complaining that republicans have
noticed what he is doing
you would think with all the public
policy debates that are taking place
right now
that you know the republican party would
be
engaged in a significant debate about
how are we going to deal with the
economy and what are we going to do
about climate change and what are we
going to do about
lo and behold the single most
important issue to them apparently right
now is critical race theory
who knew that that was the threat to our
republic
um we did because you were the one who
started promoting it
mr president you were the one who
decided that it was very important to
polarize americans along racial lines
and suggest that all the systems of
power of america were significantly
infused and indeed irredeemably infused
with white supremacy right and again
the goal here for the left is continue
to form that coalition it's all about
the coalition which is of course why
barack obama
is blaming a rise of anti-semitism on
not his own party not his own actions by
the way in supporting the iranian regime
or supporting
the palestinian regime no instead barack
obama is blaming
donald trump and republicans despite the
fact that the radical uptick in
anti-semitism we have seen over the past
couple of years
is deeply tied into the to the left-wing
ideologies that are associated with
black lives matter that are associated
with the pro-palestinian cause that are
associated with his own
sort of conspiratorial viewpoint on
hierarchies of power in the united
states
i've noticed that barack obama isn't
spending any time condemning for example
ilhan omar
who's out there comparing israel to
hamas he's only com he's only condemning
trump suggesting that trump is
responsible for anti-semitism
again this is courage according to the
left because courage
is dependent on the final goal in the
aristotelian notion
this is why barack obama's why are you
paying why are you paying attention to
critical race theory
why do you care for indoctrinating your
kids and the idea that true bravery lies
in authentically identifying as less if
they're a member of a particular race
also i'm going to stand up for the most
radical members of my coalition
okay now what this is going to lead to
of course
is eventually a breakdown in the
coalition we're going to get to that in
just
one second first let's talk about the
greatest gift for father's day the
greatest gift i'm talking about
steak yes indeed omaha steaks isn't just
steak is the best steak of your life
omaha steaks delivers guaranteed quality
and safety with every single order
every order is flash frozen vacuum
sealed safely delivered in a cooler with
dry ice it stays ready to cook in the
freezer for months go to omahasteaks.com
type shapiro in the search bar order dad
to get out and grill assortment so
they sent me like a kosher steak i'm a
steak sticks i'm special a few years ago
let me just tell you
i still recall that steak it is
unbelievable it includes
the get out and grill assortment 20
entrees your dad is guaranteed to love
like ultra juicy burgers plum chicken
breasts sides desserts four 10-ounce
butchers cut new york strips these
strips are aged for 30 days why is that
important well because age equals
tenderness plus
get four free new york strip burgers
with your order i mean let me tell you
for father's day if my wife just got me
like a box of steak that would be the
best thing in the world visit
omahastakes.com
keyword shapiro get dad the get out and
grill assortment plus
for free new york strip burgers today
send more than just a gift send him an
experience he will love and can share
with you that is omahasteaks.com
keyword shapiro go check out
omahastakes.com keyword shapiro right
now for the special deal
alrighty we're going to get to more on
this in just one second first we all
love watching candace drop truth bombs
here at the daily wire
but we are also huge fans of letting
truth trickle through our headphones on
the go which is why we've made sure
one of her best qualities her ability to
speak clearly on issues can go wherever
you go
whether she's asking donald trump
questions like whether she's gonna be on
his 2024 ticket or
getting adam corello to expose hollywood
conservatives or giving feminism the
roast it deserves with her panel of
guests
you're guaranteed a smart funny
listening experience so subscribe to and
download canvas the audio podcast on
apple spotify or whatever your platform
of choice may be
if you like what you hear be sure to
leave a five star review keep candace's
podcast at the top
of the charts you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so if the chief goal here is keeping the
coalition operative that it's all just
about the coalition
and it's got to be a woke coalition that
is designed and tearing down the system
this naturally means
that enemies must atone all who defend
any aspect of the system must be
destroyed from the most minor
to the most grave violations of the
system this is why ellie kemper has to
be forced
to apologize for being in a beauty
pageant
in like 1999 that had nothing to do with
racism at the time
and now she's being she's being forced
to apologize you'll remember her
from the office and the unbreakable
kimmy schmidt well now she has
apologized
she says hi guys when i was 19 years old
i decided to participate in a debutant
ball in my hometown
the century-old organization that hosted
the debutantes ball had an
unquestionably racist sexist and elitist
past
i was not aware of this history at the
time but ignorance is no excuse i was
old enough to have educated myself
before
getting involved well she's now done
hermea culpa
and she can she can be allowed back into
the halls of the woke she says i
unequivocally deplore denounce and
reject white supremacy
who suggested she had not at the same
time i acknowledge that because of my
race and my privilege
i am the beneficiary of a system that is
dispensed unequal justice and unequal
rewards now again
most of us in the traditional sense
would call this cowardice
because all this is is just fear that
she is going to be rejected
by a group of people who are bullies and
and totalitarians
but according to the left this is true
courage because true courage again lies
in joining the mob to tear down the
system
right they're an army on behalf of a
higher good
and this means when you're an army on
behalf of a higher good that anyone who
is a threat
has to go and right now who is the
highest threat the highest threat is joe
manchin because joe manchin is an
obstacle joe manchin
has now refused to go along with the
democratic dream of completely remaking
the way we vote in the united states
federalizing all election procedures
allowing ballot harvesting getting rid
of voter id laws
he said i'm not going to kill the
filibuster which is in fact a check and
balance
on mob rule it is a check and balance
against the predation of the mob against
individual rights which is exactly of
course what the left is looking for they
don't like individual rights they want
individual rights
tossed out the window the same way the
aclu does on behalf of progressive
causes
and joe manchin is like no we're not
doing any of that so this means that joe
manchin
is now the enemy because you're either
with the woke or you're against the woke
and right now joe manchin is not on the
side of the walk and this means that
inside his own party they've decided the
strongest move here is to attack joe
manchin now
this makes perfect sense from an
ideological perspective right from an
ideological perspective they have
dedicated themselves to the proposition
that institutions of american power are
bad
they are bad unless you can weaponize
those institutions of american power and
use them on behalf
of what causes right then they're good
right the filibuster used by chuck
schumer is good the filibuster used by
the right is bad and should be nuked
and joe manchin is standing in the way
of all of this and so now his own party
is going to war with joe manchin we'll
see how far this gets them by the way
because it turns out that you generate a
lot of resistance
to yourself and to your agenda when you
decide that it's a battle
of all against all when you decide that
it is your coalition
versus the the prevailing systems of
power and anybody who stands in the way
and argues for like neutral principles
like maybe the filibuster should stay
even if it hurts our side this time
which by the way republicans did a
couple of years ago hilarious to watch
all the members of the journalistic
endeavor suggest oh look look at trump
used to call for the end of the
filibuster now he's calling for for the
filibuster to remain
yes now do the democrats you know who
kept the filibuster the whole time
mitch mcconnell who was in the majority
anyway
joe manchin has become persona non grata
inside the democratic party james
clyburn
of south carolina who is in fact a
pretty radical politician
not quite bernie sanders openly but a
very rad and says very inflammatory
things on the issue of race on a fairly
regular basis
he decided to go after joe manchin
yesterday again it's a bold strategy to
go after a senator
from a state that voted 40 percentage
point gap
in favor of donald trump really brave
move here and by the way we've had
senator switch parties before richard
shelby did it we saw
jim jeffords do it the other way back in
the early 2000s
this is a bold move cotton we'll see how
it works out for them here's james
clyburn going after joe manchin
i would say to senator manchin you've
told us what you're or against
how about put forth the legislation that
you would like to see
pass let us see your bill
the fact of the matter is the greatest
empires in the world
came down because of decadence and a
lot of avoidance of issues it's a whole
theory that nero played his fiddle
as ron byrne but what we have
is a modern day uh fiddling around
in the senate and this democracy is on
fire
okay what's hilarious about the the
argument that he's making right now
is that the senate is ineffective so we
should just overrule it
he's like the fall of rome the fall of
the roman republic was like nero
fiddling well rome burned
okay so there are two separate falls the
fall of the roman republic and also the
fall of the roman empire two separate
things the fall of the roman republic
was people making arguments like james
clyburn right the senate is a bunch
of elderly white privileged people who
are arguing with each other all the time
and if they would just stop that we need
a dictator we need somebody to solve
this problem julius want to step in
right that was the basic idea the
dictatorship in rome began
because people were making the argument
that the legislative process in rome was
ineffective that's exactly the argument
that james clyburn is making right now
kill the filibuster
because we're not getting what we want
and then invoking the fall of rome i
mean the ignorance truly is is
sort of on display there with regard to
just basic roman history
is fairly incredible but the strategic
move here again it's an ideological move
but once you're committed you're
committed and there's no such thing as
being insufficiently committed once
you're committed to the fight
you got to be committed to the fight
jamal bowman who is a radical
congressperson from new york again from
a very blue district
he is at the ripping joe mansion as well
joe manchin has become
the new mitch mcconnell mitch mcconnell
during obama's presidency
said he would do everything in his power
to stop obama
he's also repeated that now during the
biden presidency
by saying he would do everything in his
power to stop president biden
and now joe manchin is doing everything
in his power to stop
democracy and to stop our work for the
people the work that the people sent us
here to do
no dissent will be broke institutions
must be torn down and joe manchin is in
the way
i mean it's fairly incredible you have
members of the democratic where's pelosi
right pelosi's the head of her party in
the house she's the speaker of the house
why isn't she saying to her people guys
you know we kind of need joe
joe is the swing boat instead she's like
you know what go go on tv jamal and just
rip him up
james clyburn too it's pretty incredible
jamal hill meanwhile can always be
counted on for the stupidest and most
radical take
she tweeted out this is so on brand for
this country record number of black
voters show up to save this democracy
only for white supremacy to be upheld
by a cowardly power-hungry white dude
joe manchin is a clown okay this is such
a self-contradictory
tweet let us count the ways first of all
when you say record number of black
voters show up to save this democracy
and then white supremacy is upheld um
what if a record number of black voters
showed up to save the democracy and were
not suppressed
that would suggest that there is not
massive voter suppression when a record
number of black voters show up
that that is pretty much definitionally
not voter suppression and when you say
that they voted up to
show up to save this democracy which by
the way is the argument the left was
making about how trump was a threat to
the democracy
only for white supremacy to be upheld by
a cowardly power-hungry white dude
i have a question he was the democrat
okay that guy
is is in the party that you presumably
voted for
the party of democracy so you're just
unhappy that so basically this falls
under the rubric of
everything i like is democracy and
action anything i don't like is white
supremacy
jamal has a cl i mean really just
clownish clownish stuff from jemele hill
but joy reid is there to support it
she said is this what folks on the right
are so mad about let's unpack hasn't the
filibuster been used from the post-civil
war era straight through the 1950s and
60s to uphold white supremacy
isn't manchin literally caping for that
um
i have a question barack obama upheld
the filibuster
and bragged about upholding the
filibuster and how important it was
joe biden bragged about upholding the
filibuster
but in pursuit of utopia true courage
is doing anything you can to join the
coalition of the woke
and the personal is political in this
battle the redefinition of courage
is deeply in is deeply intertwined
with the attempt to tear down all of the
systems that have made america great
i'm not talking about systems of
discrimination i'm talking about systems
of freedom individual rights
checks and balances in government
federalism all these things have to be
torn down and if you join that cause
and if you join that cause by joining
the coalition against
traditional definitions of things
ranging from sex to marriage then this
means
that you are doing something good for
the world and that is why joe biden is
paying tribute to you today
and not the people who died on d-day
alrighty we'll be back here tomorrow
with much much more
also coming up soon the matt wall show
airing at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to
check it out over at dailywire.com
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam scie events audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hera and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily dailywire2021
on the matt well show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show
you